and you're live chairman
thank you thank you bernard good evening
and welcome to this
south eastern area planning committee
meeting on wednesday
17th of february 2021
my name is councillor nick skeenes and
i'm the chair of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april
last year in a response to the covered
19 situation
please can i ask everyone present in
this meeting
to ensure your camera remains on where
broadband permits and your microphone
remains muted
when not addressing the committee this
will reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the hands up
function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
you are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function
should not be used for questions or any
other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda
papers please ensure you reference the
page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now may i ask the officers taking part
in the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with uh matt lee
good luck evening members thank you
chairman um i am matt lee lead
specialist place
and chief planning officer at morgan
district council thank you
thank you michael johnson
earth to michael johnson okay
uh derek lawrence yeah sorry chairman
unfortunate
um last minute then neither michael
johnson or derrick lawrence for
attendance so he couldn't update you on
that sorry about that
that's okay uh luis louise staplehurst
hello my name is louise staplehurst and
i'm a specialist in development
management
thank you thank you uh bernard casey
good evening members ben and casey clark
to this evening's committee thank you
chairman
thank you and are there any other
officers present
no chairman uh well before i call on the
clerk to take the roll call of committee
members
uh can i ask those counsellors in
attendance
to introduce themselves please
uh and i guess we'll start uh with uh
ann howe
uh chairman council hall is part of the
committee
i'm sorry the ones in attendance yeah i
do apologize yes sir
um chrissy morris
good afternoon and welcome are there any
other counsellors thank you uh chrissy
any other counselors in attendance not
part of the committee
i'll take that as a no uh berna please
can you now carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you chairman um members i will
call your names in alphabetical order
starting with counselor passenger
you're muted
yep good evening and you can see i'm
present thank you
thank you casabeel president good
evening everyone
councillor bell good evening everyone
i'm here
thank you councillor channel hello good
evening everyone i'm here present
thank you cancer helm
good evening present thank you castle
hull
good evening everybody yes i'm here
thank you
cancer schemes yes i'm here thank you
um just to let you know uh that's
everybody isn't it
no i am here
oh he's coming oh yeah yeah i just gave
apologies bob
yeah sorry thank you
all right thank you councillor boyce
uh members please be advised that we
have three public participants in the
meeting this evening
and i will call on them to speak at the
appropriate time
uh item two on the agenda is apologies
for absence
may i have the apologies for absence
please berna
thank you chairman we've had apologies
for absence from councillors duik
and stamp thank you
okay so we're going to item three the
minutes from the 20th of january 2021
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on this data
um which are found on pages 7 to 12 are
approved as a true and accurate record
i so move and if you wish to second that
motion please
thank you councillor health um right uh
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy please use the hands up
function to indicate and i'll invite you
to speak
okay i see no hands up uh uh
bernie you can't see anybody with hands
up can you no chairman
okay so um do you wish to agree these by
ascent
are you happy to if so say so now i
agree
chairman have you ever yeah okay those
are agreed by
ascent we go on to item four
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard
to paragraph six to eight inclusive of
the code of
conduct for members members are reminded
that they are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function
now to indicate and i will invite you to
speak uh
counselor channel could you go ahead
oh gosh thank you very much chairman my
mute button's sticking a bit
um just to declare my normal one
non-pecuniary i'm a member of essex
county council which is consulted on
planning matters to do with mostly
highways access
education and other things in its remit
that it should be consulted on
by the authority thank you thank you and
uh
you are you need to unmute yourself and
sorry sorry um i i know
mrs leslie yates um so is that
non-pecuniary
would you want me to stand down uh
when you say you know uh could there be
well i'll actually take advice
from the officers on this uh what is if
you can explain your connection to her
whether it could be pecuniary
um she's um she used to be one of our
liveries
and she's got one of my horses so she's
a
customer of yours uh yes yeah
okay um what do you feel berno is that
uh
pecuniary or non-procurement i feel it
might be bordering on pecunery
chairman okay um when you
sorry when you say uh she's got one of
our horses
is that uh
oh it was a retired force she's take it
she's got it
you know it was one of mine once yes but
so it's it's there's no business
involved in this
cancer heart is there no no
no she doesn't keep the horse at your
stable for example no not
now because she used to
do chairman um what i would advise
council is it's always your decision
and officers can't obviously tell you um
but my advice would be to consider if if
you
were looking at this at home would you
consider that
would a member of public consider that
you had a relationship that might
obscure your view um one way or the
other and that's just i'd advise you to
consider it that way it's your decision
whether or not you think you've got a
relationship that crosses line into
pecuniary or ex
but that's i said it's up to you but
that'd be this way i'd consider it i
think
it's normally if an endowed chairman and
members leave the chamber if any doubt
is in
mind right i might do that
be on the safe side okay thank you
thank you thank you very much well
that's item five council hull
council how was that that's in
connection without an item five annely
house burnham road latchington
no this is and stony hills
20.011666
yeah item thank you sorry
okay thank you very much um uh i can't
see
any other member who has indicated that
they wish to speak if uh councillor hull
you could put your hand down that
would be marvelous uh so let's move on
to item five
uh twenty uh zero zero double eight
three stroke full and the house burnham
road latchington
uh we moved to this agenda which has
found a
item which is found on pages 13-28
and in a moment i'll call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the hands up function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn please keep your points
clear and succinct
uh ms staplehurst could you please
present this report
thank you
this application seeks retrospective
planning permission for extensions to
the tea room on the site
and out buildings within the site and
also the proposed extension to the
opening hours
for the tea room and also the playing of
live music
this is the location plan showing the
sites
this is the dwelling on the site and
this is the tea room outlined in green
in terms of site history a 2014
application
approved commission for the change of
use of the rear part of the dwelling
into a tea room which you can see here
the 2014 application restricted the
opening hours
as shown
and also stated that no amplified sound
shall be
used the application proposing proposes
these following opening hours here
and then these proposed um hours of
music
and amplified sound
so you can see on thursdays to saturdays
if they're proposing to have it open
until midnight
and still later on on sundays and bank
holidays
as well
these are the plans showing the dwelling
with the team room but prior to
any of the unlawful extensions taking
place
this was um just after the 2014
application with the
tea room to the rear yeah
this is the block plan you can see the
dwelling
here and then this is the tea room to
the rear of the dwelling
these are some of the outbuildings on
the stair site which used to store
materials in relation to both the house
and the tea room use
and this is also an annex used in
relation to the dwelling
um this here is the neighbor
lillian s which has been referenced in
the reason for refusal
um due to the proximity to the site
boundary and the tea room
and concerned in relation to the noise
impact
so um this is an aerial view of the site
and just to indicate the expansion to
the tea room which has taken place
since the original application you can
see it was
relatively um small tea room in these
in these photos an extension had taken
place here and then a further extension
to the rear and to the side
that took place in 2016 and
this is the neighbor to the west and
which also has a rear projection which
isn't shown on them some of the plans
but this is the whole of the
neighboring dwelling
so this is the existing floor plan as it
is
currently with this part to the rear
this l-shaped part of the tea room
these are the existing elevations so
this is from the front you can see part
of the tea room projects to the side
and this is the team and projecting to
the rear
and the other two existing elevations
so this is from the rear this is the et
room
this is the proposed floor plan um
showing
internal toilets to be provided here
and an additional internal door lobby
area here
it's also been stated that all the
single glazed windows have been double
glazed with sound resistant units
there are no changes proposed to the
elevations
these are the floor plans of the
outbuildings
and the elevations of the outbuildings
so these photos show the view of the tea
room to the rear looking south
east so this single story part is the
tea room with the dwelling
behind it shows the dwelling from the
front
this is also the tea room this is the
main entrance
the door here into the tea room
i'm just just showing the whole rear
projection
some further photos showing the tea room
within the site
and then these two photos show uh the
neighbor and how
close it is to the boundary and it's
sort of the original part of the
dwelling and then
this extension projecting to the north
these photos show some of the additional
um double glazing that's been installed
a customer notice in relation to noise
and some photographs of the outbuildings
overall the additional development and
extensions that have taken place on the
site are considered on balance to be
acceptable
however it's considered that it has not
been demonstrated that the extension of
the opening hours
particularly into the evening in
combination
with the playing of amplified sound
would not have an impact a detrimental
impact on the
western neighbor particularly due to
their close proximity all the way along
the
shared boundary thank you chairman
thank you very much we have one public
participant
uh for this planning application uh in
line with the public participation
scheme i now invite the applicant
uh mrs tina lightman to read out her
submission
and may i remind you please that you are
allocated two minutes only for public
speaking
in accordance with this scheme uh go
ahead please uh mrs lightman
can you hear me yep my name is tina
likeman
and i have been um the owner of on the
latch for the last two years
i applied straight away for a music
license i've as i've been a singer all
my life
i have put music events on from day one
i've always informed my neighbours of
anything i was planning to do
and um and i am very aware of my
neighbors as i live here
and i intend to for a long time and i
don't upset anyone
i've put on events um on many occasions
and i've not had one complaint
in two years i have done several things
to prevent
any inconvenience to anybody else i've
had high performance windows um the
fitted doors
uh like you say acoustic glass even
though
i've had a test done recently and we was
like sand test and we was well under the
limit
i have signs everywhere asking people to
leave the premises quietly
and be considerate of my neighbors my
direct neighbour
is in full support of us that's the one
you're talking about
i'm not a drinker so i'm fully in
control of my business
my customers are middle age and upwards
and they only go out looking
for a good time not for any trouble we
have hundreds of followers on facebook
and social media all with very very
positive feedback
i wouldn't want to upset anyone this is
the third application now and i'm sure
my neighbors have had more than enough
time to voice any concerns they may have
had
but they haven't i am trying to run a
successful stress-free environment for
everyone to come and enjoy their self
within with no trouble calls to anybody
else i have
been in ownership for the last two years
and i've achieved just that
um i will and continue to work with
malden district council
thank you for your time this is very
important to me my family
the staff and the local community to
make on the lot
success thank you sorry i'm really
nervous that's all right
uh thank you very much indeed um right
just a couple of uh things
um first of all uh could i just want to
confirm
there was did i uh do i understand it
correctly that uh
the tea room was small in the first
place and then it developed without
permission and this is
effectively retrospective uh permission
that we're looking for
i heard a comment to the effect that um
from the staplehurst that uh um
this uh this the the
development has been acceptable uh
considered acceptable is that correct
uh through you chairman um it's correct
that it was just a smaller extension
um initially and then additional
extensions have um taken place
since then uh but we do consider that
the operational development that's
taken place in terms of the extensions
and the outbuildings is acceptable
and it's just the concern in relation to
the neighbour
and the noise and the opening hours
thank you chairman
thank you and as i hear um uh tina
lightman says that the neighbors aren't
bothered of course
we don't have any way of confirming that
independently
and i would remind all members that uh
just like social media
sometimes people don't want a public
comment in public so
we have to take care of that um so let's
uh
move on uh the recommendation is set out
within the report
is as follows that the the planning
application
uh twenty zero zero eight eight three
stroke full and the house burnham road
latchington v refused for the reasons as
detailed in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
vanessa bell your hands up but you're
muted are you i can't see
i am yes sorry that wasn't to second no
that was to speak apologies mr chairman
okay do i have any seconders for this
okay there being no seconders um
what happens now do i have to come up
with a suggestion that they'd be
approved and then we discuss that no you
can you can still move the
recommendation without a secondary
cancer schemes and go on to the
discussion
okay okay well then i will do so and
we'll move on to the discussion
uh um and i see that a hand is up uh
councillor bell what would you like to
say thank you mr chairman
um yeah i do i do
have concerns about the opening hours my
my alarm bells ring with anything that
goes beyond
11 o'clock particularly on a weekday we
are
you know the dengue is a rural area
we're not a city
and in my my my experience
don't want this to come out wrongly of
kind of local
nightlife pubs restaurants etc is they
close at 11
so so i'm concerned about the midnight
that that is an issue for me thank you
thank you um councillor passenger
there we are trying to take my hand down
if i can there we are
thank you mr chairman um i was actually
the council that called this in
so um what i would like to say is that
um having read the report and listening
to the presentation just now
one of the most important things i feel
is that uh the word that it's an
important
source of employment to the local
community
and and a hub for the local community i
don't really know the tea rooms myself i
don't use the tea rooms
but this is a retrospective application
for the buildings
and i think as we can see from the
officers report there doesn't seem to be
any reason why we cannot legalize these
buildings
um i believe the business
was bought before i think the
the the buildings were actually put in
place um before
um this the new applicant actually
bought the business so it's not as
though they've extended it themselves
so they bought the business in good
faith i believe the buildings were
already there
and as i say there doesn't seem to be
any reason from the officers
actually why we shouldn't allow this
application to go through the main
concern
seems to be about the opening hours i'd
also like to say that
um they have already been granted
an alcohol license and a license to play
music and live entertainment so the real
issue
seems to be mainly about the outside
space
and the opening hours so
i really feel because it's you know this
is quite an important
hub for this community latching doesn't
have a lot going on
there isn't a lot going on for people
sort of of my age and
plus who kind of you know are not really
interested in being in nightclubs as
such
and so i would really like to move that
we approve this application
and then you know with conditions
possibly for the opening hours
but uh i i really think this is this is
something that we could do
and and would be a good thing to do for
this community
thank you very much councillor passenger
councillor hal
i'm unmuted
i would like to agree with um councillor
bassinger uh we do use
on the latch from where we are it's a
good um central point
from all the dengy uh we don't have to
travel too far
um and i would like to approve it
thank you very much councillor boyce
um thank you chairman um we
we can't amend this planning application
and the concern is about
uh music and the late night music um
i believe that it is a good business
and it should be supported however
i i had this serious concern
about the late night music
planning and the local licensing
[Music]
committee are not the same thing because
it's
had its consent granted for its life
of music license and alcohol license
doesn't mean to say that the planning
would be the same um could i
ask a question of the presenting
officer about
lawful development if as
i think council of passengers said these
buildings
have been present um for a number of
years before the
purchaser bought them would they have a
lawful development certificate um
ability to be grounded
chairman through you
uh yes please uh would as miss
staplehurst would you like to comment on
that
through you chairman um it's possible
that if the applicant
wishes um to submit a lawful development
certificate
um for the buildings on the site then
that is a possibility they
um they can do that but that isn't
what's been applied for
um at the moment so the application's
been assessed as a
planning application rather than um
sort of against the time limit criteria
in relation to
immunity from enforcement yeah
uh chairman um thank you that was the
answer i
um um expected um however
that does seem that the applicant will
not
need to be too concerned about
retrospective permission for the
buildings themselves
i will have to think on whether i'm
going to support
the applicant on this or the officer's
recommendation
because the music is
a serious matter thank you
thank you um good counsellor boyce um uh
council boys if you could put your hand
down michael
uh councillor helm uh i believe you're
next
thank you mr chairman um if you take
yours
go to 3.1.13
uh additional closing has been windows
will be shut and they don't
open because they've got air
conditioning and maybe condition that
the
the patio doors the patio are shut as
well
and nobody outside while live music is
being played
thank you mr chairman thank you yes sir
just considering that
i think the practicalities are that in
the summer
and in the heat air conditioning or no
people will be coming in and out the
doors will open sometimes doors will be
left open
uh unaware um without intent
uh my my feeling is i might as well say
it now that uh
i'm generally in favor of this but i do
have problems with
like with uh music licenses that go go
beyond
11 o'clock uh on to councillor bell
thank you um so am i right in thinking
that we can't amend this because i would
have suggested that we amend it and that
we
say opening until 11. yes can i pass
that on to
um mike lee or indeed a louis
staplehurst uh it seems to me that
there's
no reason why we couldn't revise the
conditions but i may be wrong and
counsel about voice may well be right
um thank you chairman for you um in most
instances
a council has to determine the
application that is submitted to it
and council boyce is correct that we
can't amend an application we don't have
the gift to do that
but the slight difference with this is
that this is actually in relation to
a condition which is separate to the
operational development that's ongoing
so we would have the power to
determine the application relation to
the built form the physical operational
development
and then impose conditions as we see fit
it's no different
to if it was a whole new application and
it was for
a shop and they wanted to be open to a
certain time
and we just for example we sometimes
actually give
longer hours than what the shoppers ask
for because well they might want to be
open those hours we give
an appropriate time frame so when it
comes to conditions we do have a little
bit of freedom
that we wouldn't have if it wasn't if it
was just we were
discussing a rear door and a rear
extension and we only liked part of it
or something like that
so that when it comes to conditions yes
there is ability to maybe be a little
bit more flexible
thank you chairman thank you i'm going
to come to councillor passenger in a
minute but uh councillor china hasn't
spoken yet
sorry i hadn't quite finished mister
sorry so that's that's helpful so that i
would propose i would propose that then
as a condition but
just to know i have direct experience of
something similar to this having lived
next door but one
to such a venue and it doesn't matter
how much you've got in the way of noise
insulation every time that door opens
and someone enters or someone leaves
you are hit by a wall of sound so just
so
people are aware of that but i would
suggest we condition opening till 11.
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
councillor
chana channel thank you very much
chairman um
i'm largely um well certainly in support
of the business and certainly i would
declare i live in author but not near to
the venue
i've only heard very good things about
it and
i was interested in the environmental
health actually comments
which actually i i thought sounded
positive and
it actually indicated matters could be
dealt with by condition
i think they did highlight about outside
but otherwise they were saying certain
things could be dealt with by conditions
rather than
the officer can you please tell me have
we from environmental health and i can't
see anything on the report and the
office hasn't mentioned it and the um
the lady who runs the business has
indicated she's been having events
have we ever had any um complaints about
noise about that venue um regardless of
what time or
day it is because um i couldn't see that
as a negative at all within the
report so i'm assuming there has been
none at all which makes me
feel very much persuaded um to see this
not as an issue that would necessarily
cause fundamental distress um in the
area
because i think it's probably been
operating for a while
and i'd just like some responses to
those sort of inquiries please if
possible chairman
thank you yes uh um uh louis staplehurst
can you help us with that
through you chairman um i'm not aware of
um whether any complaints have been
received by environmental health
um but i would like to sort of emphasize
that
we need to um sort of view the
application
um in perpetuity and even if the
neighbor hasn't um objected or no one
sort of had concerns up until this point
and the site may well be well managed at
the moment
um but if it changed hands or if another
neighbour moved in next door
and then the situation and could change
so we do need to
sort of look at the application in the
future as well thank you
thank you councillor passenger
thank you mr chairman i would just like
to pick up from where
councillor helm left off really and just
to say that
you know the the the windows don't open
there's air conditioning
um they say in the report that they are
putting a screen
so should the door open that would um
that would muffle the sound
um they've also um
done various tests which i know you know
great db
expert in sound but uh the last test
it seemed to me was less than the
ambient sound
when they did a test from from the from
the uh
from the borders border i believe so it
seems to me as if
um you know everybody's done as much as
they can
um there doesn't seem to be any
complaints they seem
you know as far as i'm aware they're on
good terms with neighbours and i do
understand going forward
this could all change but in a way
you know as we're always told we
shouldn't be you know we should be
dealing with what we're dealing with
right now
and what we're dealing with now is this
application with with these people
at this moment and yes going forward i
agree you know who knows how it would be
managed but it seems to me
it's being managed very well it seems to
have a great deal of support in the
community that's that's all i know
and and i say a great source of
employment so
i would now you know like to put forward
that we approve this application and
then
maybe um if mr lee can help with some
conditioning
if if we have concerns
so uh in front of us we have the
recommendation
which uh oh matt lee you have your hand
up
go ahead thank you just uh
it's okay to make it pick up a couple of
points that have been raised by members
and mistakers have sort of covered a
little bit and some members have as well
but i thought i'd maybe
make a bit comment on them for clarity
as council boys said you know planning
and licensing committee and
considerations
are very different um and
when just because a license is granted
doesn't mean that the planning should
automatically follow they do have
different considerations
um issues such as public amenities much
more
important in the planning judgment than
it is in the licensing judgment and
that therefore is an important
consideration for yourself members as
decision makers going forward tonight
um has already been explained
um if we go out planning permission for
this with new conditions
and that are more generous they will sit
on that permission for its life
so irrespective of the current use of
the site as in
how people behave who owns it the
reasonable management
of the site etc those cannot be
expected to sit in perpetuity further
because there may be a change in owner
customer clientele etc and what we have
to look at is the conditions that we can
impose
that can protect the immunity of the
adjoining residents in perpetuity
um and i know as i say they've got to
determine the application in front of us
but
that is the yeah what i was also trying
to explain is that is the potential of
the application in front of us not just
the physical nuts and bolts so like we
have to consider how it could grow or
change without the need for planning
permission in the future
and it's the little things such as
conditions and all these little things
that we add in
to protect the development in long term
such as moving pedia rights it was on a
house and all those sort of things and
that's really what we have to be
conscious of here is that just because
the current
applicant you know does everything well
doesn't mean if they were to sell it in
you know if they won the lottery and
walked away in six months you know um
it wouldn't necessarily be the same
people with the same professionalism
um my understanding is that we
haven't had any enforcement uh
complaints about noise but also we
haven't been made aware that they've
ever even been any action or events
outside of the approved hours so
um i think we can only give that
statement from the applicant limited
value because
without knowing the frequency of them
knowing that what times they are
they wouldn't necessarily be a direct
comparison to what the is being proposed
today
um you know the hours are quite late um
if it was
if you knew an event was happening until
six o'clock it happened occasionally in
your neighbor you may be more
accommodating than if it was
every night and it's a lot later but
without any of that information
well more than just a comment made by
the applicant as decision makers we
should give it the way
that we can based on the facts that we
have we have very limited
facts on that point so i think members
just need to be slightly
wary of the value that they give to
those comments um
what i would say in relation to noise is
that
there's a very big difference i think
it's half past three or something at the
moment the hours
are for the business it's a very big
difference between that and midnight or
even that and 11 o'clock at night
um how noise works is relates to
background ambient noise and
in the density it's pretty quiet anyway
all of the day but obviously later into
the evening
it gets much quieter and the ability for
the background noise to hide and to mask
any
noises from a noise from so it's a
business whether it's
yourself in your garden whatever it's
much more difficult to hide it
and those noises are able to spread and
travel much further
um we also need to think about the
decorum the behavior of
the public coming and going from the
site we can't control that either
through planning really or through
environmental health
um and i think it's roughly um the
human voice is about 60 decibels um so
if
late at night as people come and go if
it's shutting at midnight 11 o'clock
that noise from those
people coming and going will be quite um
extensive and it's you know
it's accepted fact that you know the
decorum of uh
people that are leaving alcoholic
10 years late at night isn't always
perfect that is a consideration where
we need to take into account protecting
them the public so
i do think members need to be very
conscious of the fact that if we do
grant this permission
there is real potential for harm because
our environmental health team are not
comfortable with the level of
information and detail that they have to
say
it would not be it would not protect the
neighbors if we do grant planning
permission
there will be harm so members of
potential for harm so i think members
need to be very conscious of that
in relation to councillor bell's point
about 11 o'clock um
it's a suggested amendment i'll be
concerned to go that late
without having more information um i
think there is potential for maybe later
than half past three
but i think we've just got to be very
conscious i would always advise members
to be pragmatic when it comes to the
amenity of
uh residents of the district thank you
okay thank you
uh matt uh that makes me think that
there may be a case then for
uh refusing it on the grounds that do
they
i assume that they get another three
free go at this is am i correct in that
uh matt lee
in other words that they could come back
with more information and proposals
for the hours that might be more likely
accepted
is that correct matt lee that that this
wouldn't cost them more
given the fact we're uncovered and no
didn't go there anyway at the moment
i'm just checking the planning history
for you chairman i believe that the uh
the free go has been
used um this is yeah this is the second
application
at the site thank you chairman they
would obviously be able to appeal to
the secretary of state which is free as
well there's no fee for that
if we do to accuse the application
right okay uh councillor helm
is next thank you very much mr chairman
pubs have extraordinary hours at that
sometimes they're granted
but they don't always use them and it
might be the same here
they might just need to use them as now
and again for a
party birthday party something like that
this isn't probably
they're going to use it all the time
it'll only be just now and again
because there's only a need when you
have big parties or something like that
and i think we should pass it as it is
and to curtail a business like this is
ridiculous we need businesses in this
country and if you're going to try and
put them all out of business well
that's the way things are going at the
moment thank you thank you yes i don't
think we're trying to put them out of
business but uh i understand your
commenter counselor hull
and then i'd like to wrap this up as
soon as possible please
sorry i i just i just like to say
you know we do need businesses like this
in this area
and we were lucky enough to be given a
license but it didn't work for us
because it wasn't you know we didn't
have enough people to to organize it but
we've still got a license
and we use it and hopefully it you know
if people don't use it they won't
they won't need the license thank you
councillor passenger
uh yeah thank you mr chairman uh mr
chairman i i agree
um with councillor helm i think um you
know
this to to make this a viable business
we should grant this
and i have made a proposal and my
proposal is to approve this application
so um that's my proposal i think that's
the only one on the table at the moment
isn't it
yeah well thank you yes well at the
moment
thank you we have the officers
recommendation
yes we have the officer's recommendation
we has not been seconded yet
so i'll ask one more time for a second
for refusal
is there a secretary yes councillor bell
that's the bell his second refusal so
therefore we'll have to
vote on refusal as it stands
um so i therefore uh ask
berna would you please uh take i don't
think this is going to go through on
ascent
so would you please berna take a vote on
this
uh yes gentlemen just bear with me and
i'll call the
voting sheets up um
members i will take your names in
alphabetical order
can you please state clearly for against
our abstain
starting with councillor bassinger
against
thank you cancer beale
abstain thank you chairman
so that's two for the officer's
recommendation of refusal
five against and one abstention
okay so that means that uh it has not
been refused
uh and therefore we will go to mark
bassinger's
proposal that it be uh when i'm going to
put words into your mouth counselor
bastard and you tell me if i'm wrong
that this application be approved
subject to planning conditions to is
that that what you want or are you
saying cancer passenger
uh to be accepted as it is uh
i i think mr chairman i would say um
as it is to be honest okay well that is
the proposal on the table do i have a
seconder
counselor please chairman
clarity um that
they would even if so we would need
conditions
in respect of what times we were looking
to put on if we didn't do it with any
conditions they're able to be open 24 7.
so my advice would be that first things
see two things one is that i may be
advised on something
like this that you thinking about the
suite of conditions that could be quite
complex is that they're delegated to
officers
um through uh consultation with yourself
um and um second obviously we need a
reason for approval as well
a reason for approval uh well okay
um can i um ask the people who have uh
uh
i'll start with counselor helm could you
give me a reason for approval this is a
long-standing business that is uh well
stood in the community
and a much needed uh meeting place for
people to meet and
be entertained thank you okay
we're looking for planning reasons i
guess i'm not sure whether that
that is correct council of passenger
yeah thank you mr man i mean i i called
this on a policy e1 and in five
and uh so those are the two policy
numbers that i call this on
and that's to do with tourism and uh
employment
in the local area i don't know if that
would survive
oh matt lee would that suffice
chairman um
reasons for approval are materially
different to reasons
for refusal where to be honest i'm able
to give quite a lot of help and support
which is not so available the reason for
approval case laws cleared with that a
member of public must be able to watch
this committee and
understand and know why members have
gone the way they have readings refusal
i'm
able to give a lot more advice as long
as it's been discussed we can put it
together so
but what i'll say is as always with
members you need to think about
really the reason for refusal and your
reason for approval either needs to talk
to that reason for refusal as in
you know they say design's a nice simple
one where officers say it's unattractive
members go we think it's fine
so they the reason for approval either
looked at or
that you think the benefits outweigh the
harm such as
it's contrary to policy but x but
because of why
the benefits are better for the district
than sticking to the policy
um i would raise some concerns with
councillor helms
point because that would infer that
remembering every decision we make as a
committee affects the whole council
and you would infer from councillor
helms point that
almost any business outweighs protecting
harm because
council sorry outweighs protecting the
munitive neighbours because
the statement that says i'm not saying
that this is what council helm
was saying but at the end of the day
this will be the council's decision and
it can be
used against us and in another committee
there's been some a couple of unusual
decisions let's say and they're already
starting to be quoted us
appeals so especially with the
remoteness lots of agents are seeing
lots of our committees so
i just think we need to be very careful
and specific where
you know you know accounts bash what i
would say is that you know
i said i can't give limited advice but
you did talk about your
consideration of the noise assessment
and how actually you think it's not
actually going to necessarily cause any
harm so
you know you have raised that i would
think that would be a logical thing to
look towards as a bit of guidance
thank you sharon thank you uh councillor
china
thank you very much chairman uh what i
was going to say is um
well mr lee sort of jumped in and said
it we do need conditions and actually
when you read the environmental health
response i think
there's suggestions in there what can be
mitigated by conditions
the whole response on the order paper
and it does make rare suggestions so i
would say
um to support um and obviously define
what the reason for approval is and then
i would say delegate to yourself
chairman
income um to mr lee in consultation with
yourself to make sure the conditions do
cover
perhaps those issues that environmental
health have suggested
um form part of the conditions of the
approval
uh okay that sounds good um uh
matt lee are you have you got uh
in your head anywhere from the
discussion that we've said
a possible reason for approval
as i said i can't really
just say very different to a reason's
refusal and i can't
give members their reason for approval
it does need to come from yourselves and
it's
member of public needs to have seen what
the members were doing
um and as i said i've given some advice
on what points were discussed and what i
think you should look towards
but i'm i said it's very materially
different between approval and refusal
and
i'm unable to really i can't give you
that
things i hope hopefully i've given you
some pointers that might have
clearly given you some indication what
might form a good
reason i'm not sure i entirely followed
them but uh
what i will say is is that uh uh clearly
there
there seems to be in this committee a
mood to approve i would suggest that one
reason
uh for approval might be that uh that
we're happy that the
um that the development there
can be legalized uh uh
based on precedent and that therefore we
will approve it subject to
um conditions uh organized by the
officers does that
does that amount to anything meaningful
matt lee
um if members wish to go that that's in
their gift yeah
but i'd definitely advise that
conditions to delegate
to officers taking into account the
complexity of this application
okay all right so councillor passenger
thank you so i'd just like to say that
you know maybe one one of the reasons
could be
that uh uh the the applicants have
mitigated the sound issues that were
brought up by the environmental people
and have um in fact you know there is
there we have now um solved that problem
and so therefore
that would be a reason to approve okay
i think we probably discussed this
enough where i think we're as clear
where we're going
uh the proposal is uh that uh
this application be approved uh subject
to conditions
uh a suite of conditions sorted out by
uh
under delegation by the officers uh so
let's vote on this uh
in consultation with you chairman i i i
did say um delegated to officers in
contact
consultation with you as chairman yes
sure okay that's fine
fine by me um so to moving on to a vote
can we uh please have the role called
further
yes chairman can i just double check who
who seconded councillor bassinger's
proposal please
uh i think it was councillor helm but
i'm not quite sure
yeah because very very quickly okay
thank you members i will take your names
in alphabetical order
we're now voting to approve the
application subject to conditions being
delegated to officers in consultation
with the chairman
and ward members i i'll start the vote
with councillor passenger can you please
state clearly for
against or abstain thank you four
thank you bernie thank you councillor
beale
that's a bell against
the
[Music]
[Music]
thank you members that concludes the
vote we've got um
four sorry five for the applicant for
approval
uh two against and one abstention
thank you very much moving on then to uh
item six
twenty zero one one double six stroke
full
land south of charwood and east of
orchard house stoney hills
burnham on crouch pages 29-54 uh
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application has been
circulated prior to this meeting
uh in a moment i'll call on the officer
to present this item members
a reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make
this known by using the hands up
function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
make keep your points
clear and succinct um staple hearse
please could you
present your report sorry chairman
quickly was counsellor
hull staying for this item i wasn't
quite sure yes that's correct yeah
you want to say something counsellor
you'll need to unmute yourself counselor
help
okay yes i think i should go okay
thank you very much sorry can i just ask
go ahead i just wanted a clarification
from cancer hull
because this is in effect our last item
so i just wanted to double check with
councillor hall did you want to be
called back into the meeting
just for the closure because this is the
last item on the agenda
i don't mind you can leave it thank you
okay thank you very much bye-bye
thank you
go ahead thank you planning publishing
is sought for the construction of an
access road and one dwelling and as as
has been stated please note the members
update with
additional public comments
this is the location plan where you can
see the site
in red here um three dwellings have been
approved
here here and here in the blue area
and another six dwellings have been
approved um to the south
here this is the neighbor of orchard
house
and this is a new dwelling which is
under construction
these site plans show the other
dwellings approved within the wider area
on this plan and a closer view of the
relationship between
the site and the two neighboring
dwellings
to the west
these are the proposed floor plans
and these are the proposed elevation
plans
this application is a resubmission of a
previously refused outline application
that application was refused due to
concerns
um regarding overlooking from the juliet
balcony at orchard house
which is here um
so concerns um overlooking this rear
part
here under this application
you can see that the dwelling has been
repositioned so that there
is no usable amenity area
between the dwelling and orchard house
the garden area is to the south
here so they are no longer concerned in
relation to a lot of privacy to the
application site
the new dwelling being constructed here
is considered to be located at a
sufficient distance
so it would not directly overlook the
amenity area of the application site
it's noted that concerns have been
raised in an objection letter with
regard to the impact of the proposal on
orchard
house to the west regarding
overshadowing and an impact on their
view
it's noted that this neighbor has a
seating area between the dwelling and
the application site here
the proposed dwelling would be visible
from this neighboring site
however the loss of a view is not a
material planning consideration
whilst there could be a minor impact on
the sunlight to the neighboring garden
when the sun is particularly low in the
sky
due to the separation distance of 9.2
metres between the two dwellings
and the fact that the proposed wearing
would be single story
it's not considered that there would be
such a material or detrimental impact
in planning terms that would justify the
refusal of the application
it is noted that permitted development
rights will be removed in relation to
outbuildings and extensions slash
dormers on the dwelling
so no further development would occur at
the site that would
impact the neighbour in terms of a loss
of privacy or a loss of light
photos show an orchard house here
and the newly constructed dwelling um
from the
street scene and then a further view of
orchard house from the front
this is the view uh southeast along the
proposed access
so this would follow through here and
the dwelling would be
up to the side here and then this is the
views the dwelling would be
approximately here and that's the rear
of orchard house
you can see this is the rear of orchard
house with the juliet balcony um that
would have overlooked the amenity area
in the previous application
and then further photos of the rear
orchard house and then this is the rear
of the newly constructed dwelling
overall when taken into account the
planning history for the area and all
material considerations
it's considered that development can be
found acceptable and would not have a
materially harmful impact on
neighbouring sites
it's therefore recommended for approval
thank you chairman
thank you very much we have two public
participants um for this
planning application firstly may i call
on mrs yates an objector to read out her
submission
and mrs yates you are allocated two
minutes only for public speaking in
accordance
with the scheme please feel free to
start
hello i've also supplied and for
reference
and further photos that are more
accurate and actually will depict how
narrow
and what minimum separation distance
there is going to be
between the two and i'd also like to say
i've tried to keep this as concise as i
can but it's very difficult when you're
living in this day in day out
to actually show you so i'd like you to
make reference to the photographs that i
have took
from my bedroom while sitting on my bed
and this is my master bedroom that i've
had to
move out because of the workmen that are
actually frequent in this area
where the perspective build is going to
go i actually can't live
in my bedroom with my husband
because i'm so exposed and for reference
a juliet balcony consists of four
floor-to-ceiling windows that aren't
glazed like a bed
like a bathroom these are clear view
windows
that are higher than five foot eight
high they're six foot high
and they cover nearly the whole span of
my bedroom
and across the whole back of my house
our main habitable
areas of room there's not even an
ability to be able to put secure
screening trees that have to be nearly
30 foot high
so i will if i may get my
two minutes and try and get as much in
as i can
right we have provided extension of
extensive
objection letters and photographs for
visual accuracy as previous
plans submitted by the developer have
not correctly shown the location of
orchard house
therefore as existing residents are
entitled to a greater degree of privacy
to their rear garden boundary
the 45 degree rule needs to be
considered and the less than 10
meters separation distance to this
backland infill development
is crucial to your decision of this
application
photographs have been sent to make
reference
orchard houses plot was the end of a
garden belonging to myrtle cottage
hence the position of the house on the
plot and the lack of amenity area to the
rear
as seen from the photographs provided
the rear of orchard house
has clear low level privacy sensitive
windows
across the whole rear elevation and in
situ at juliet balcony serving the
master bedroom
the design was approved by planning less
than six years ago
with the knowledge of a narrow amenity
area to make use of not a view
but an open outlook of two acres of
beautiful meadowland
filled with wildlife and natural
landscaping avoiding
an open outlook directly behind
we strongly object and oppose the
amended application for this
unacceptable development
loss of privacy intrusion obstruction
removal of an open outlook severe loss
of natural light
unacceptable overshadowing and the loss
of amenity
due to the less than acceptable
separation distance
between the house and the proposed
development
a mere 9.6 meters that's less than 30
foot and you're sticking a 2 000 square
foot
bungalow in between a building of this
massive structure at such
close proximity particularly from our
bedroom
with no possibility for surrounding
mature screening trees or hedging at
less than 10 metres distance through our
home
will have an important effect on the
area and quality of life for us
as residents we will be hemmed in and
overlooked
and not be able to live
thank you thank you very much we're
going to have to stop you there um
that sound is the sound of uh your time
running out but you've made your point
very well mrs yates and uh thank you
thank you much for your contribution
uh we now um uh i now call upon mr rowe
the agent to read his submission
mr o you also allocated two minutes only
for public speaking in accordance with
the scheme
good evening chairman of members thank
you for the opportunity to speak i'm
stuart ray the agent for the applicant
members
have seen the background to the
application and this site would be the
only undeveloped plot in
the middle of what would be a a street
of nine bungalows
it was left out of the earlier
applications has been explained
um because of concerns not about the
impact of the new building on
an orchard house but because of the
risk of overlooking from that juliet
balcony and orchard house to the rear
garden of the proposed bungalow
that that was the the sole issue um
the uh the agents sorry the architect
the scheme architects worked with
your planning officers and the uh the
scheme has been amended effectively to
position the building so that it
intervenes in those views and that a
private immunity of the new bungalow is
created
i mean i'm not aware of a 45 degree rule
that the object has raised there is no
such rule
and there won't be a loss of privacy
because this is a bungalow there are no
rear-facing windows
uh at all so there you can't look from
the ground floor up into a
and a first floor window where you're
gonna have boundary fences
uh et cetera so i don't accept that
point um
so really i i commend the um officer's
report to the committee it's very
thorough it deals with all the issues
that have been raised
and these aren't unusual issues in areas
like this
um and i hope members feel able to
approve it this evening thank you
thank you very much um right well the
recommendation
as set out within the report is as
follows
that uh the planning application 20
strokes zero
one one six six stroke full land south
of childhood and east of orchard house
tony hill's burma crouch
be approved subject to assigned
unilateral undertaking
to confirm that developer will
contribute to essex
host rams and the conditions as detailed
in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second the
motion
please now your microphone
and say your name pass second that
council helm
councillor helm is seconding that thank
you
i will now invite members to make any
comments uh that they
would uh see fit upon the report uh let
it starting i believe with
vanessa
um thank you mr chairman firstly i'd
invite mr ro just to put
45 degree rule into google and you will
find that it is very much a thing
apologies so uh
i know we have many many applications at
stony hills and there are
always much ringing of hands and with a
heavy heart and
that we have lost appeals at stony hills
but members this is different
this application is different this
application represents
serious serious loss of immunity
loss of privacy loss of quality of life
for the residents of orchard house the
juliet balcony the windows are
floor-to-ceiling windows
the property is less than 10
meters away from orchard house the
side of the building so nobody goes out
to put their bins out and looks up
the there may be no windows but it's
still the property we have to look
at the proximity and we have to look at
the requirements of the essex design
guide because members they're not being
met
with by this proposal
looking at it looking at the photographs
looking at
the block plans it is a clear
case of over-development and whilst i
acknowledge
the inspector's comments about stony
hills becoming
more of a suburban area this isn't
suburban this is
high-density pylum high
bungalow or not it's still an enormous
building
and i do not think this meets the
planning requirements and i do not think
it is acceptable development members
thank you thank you very much councillor
bell
uh councillor channel um
um could you just please put up the um
plan again whereby it shows the bungalow
and orchard house and the proximity to
now the boundary uh
well the separating brand i guess the
fence because i think you said it had
been
um moved back so and the garden was now
at the side so
yes can you just point out then um
i'm just looking at the red line so the
the uh
you i think you said it moved um sort of
towards the
the boundary more towards orchard house
has it not imp
position through you chairman uh
the yes so you can see here this the
house is
um sort of further uh central to the
plot
sort of um giving a larger amenity area
here
and it also showed there was a rear door
um so it sort of encouraged
the use of this area um as
garden area um and also the fact that
the garden would have been
the main garden would have been
separated from the house by the driveway
and so that's been amended um nose
doors to the back it's moved closer to
this boundary
um so this wouldn't be sort of a usable
amenity area
all of the um doors open out onto the
garden space to the south
thank you thank you can i please our
supplementary chairman
what's the height of um the proposed
running please can i just see that the
plans of that again please
okay so 5.7 meters
so 5.7 meters okay
um i do actually chairman i'm afraid i
mean 5.7 meters is well over
16 16 foot in my book in fact quite a
bit more than that
um 8 17 18 oh well 18 probably
um and that's quite high i mean bearing
in mind the height of a six foot fence
or whatever whatever the boundary is
so you're talking about three times that
in the height of the building
um i have real concerns also actually
the design of the building hearing
there's no windows or anything
in the back now that might have been
done to help the situation but
i would say on design um that's enough
um grounds and and i know we can resign
um
refuse on design alone but i i do
actually think there will be
um loss of light to the rear immunity
space of orchard house
um i recognize what the officers say but
i think the juxtaposition of that
proposed new dwelling
will affect um will affect and meaning t
and i do believe the layout of it
orientation and it proximity
uh proximity does actually cause
probably demonstrable harm
um to the immunity and residential
immunity or living conditions
of orchard health so i have very grave
concerns about this proposal chairman
very grave thank you very much um
i think that's all the counsellors uh um
who
want to speak are there any other
counselors who would like to comment
uh i don't see that there yes councillor
uh
passenger please go ahead great
um there we go thank you mr chairman i
would just just really like to
again um pick up on what counselor
channel has said when i look at the
design of that and i see a whole
back wall with no windows i think
you know it looks like you know a bit of
a pig and a poker it looks like
you know we're putting a square peg into
a round hole it's sort of been juxta
acceptable but even for the people that
buy that property and live in that with
a design like that
again it just looks like very bad design
if i if i look at a whole house
and there's a whole wall a whole back
area with no windows at all
you just think well there's something
you know intrinsically wrong there the
design is
incorrect so my feeling is very much
is in line with um counselor channel to
be honest
thank you thank you okay um i see that
leslie
yates is asking to speak again but i'm
afraid i can't let you
speak again uh it's just the way that
the rules go but as you can see
uh your points are being put across so
i'm sure you're
content at least i hope you are at this
stage anyway uh so
now um we've had the um recommendation
uh to be chairman is
you're quite right sorry thank you
chairman um
just um a relatively quick point um
in relation to a couple points quickly
the 45 degree angle
um matter that was discussed um i'm
assuming that that relates to what was
discussing the impact on
light that we normally take from but
that's
normal let me get the teeth back in i
think what the problem is
that's normally taken from a property to
you to the side and that's how it's
looked at so there isn't really a 45
degree
from the other distance um because how
you work out the 45 degrees both
angle upwards and and angle outwards so
um i don't i'm fit to fail would have to
meet both so a distance of 10 meters
would probably
mean that the 45 degree angle would not
fail because it's a two-part test
um i'd just like to highlight in
relation to
outlook from the neighbor the
the council would not have granted
permission taken to counter the property
look towards the field because that is
not something we could protect
that would not have been a material
consideration for determination of an
application because
there is no right to protect that field
and
the only issue i'd also been
highlighting particularly in relation to
design and mr tape was can you pull up
the elevations again
i just noticed that members mentioned
that um
as members know design is subjective um
there's a level of personal taste in
that and when we look to a fuse and
application we've got to show that there
is
demonstrable harm what i would say
is that this application center has
taken
a design approach to reflects the nature
of the site
and it has resulted in the rear
elevation having no fenestration or no
doors
however the fact that that is the rear
elevation
shouldn't really be a consideration per
se
um the application should be looked at
in its hole in its entirety
um i live in a house quite now that has
a side elevation with no windows my last
house had no windows inside my parents
house has no windows at the side
so it's not unusual to have properties
that have
one elevation or two elevations with no
fenestration or opening no windows
and irrespective of any other points i
would advise members to
not look at raising any concerns with
the design because
i think to say that just because there
is an elevation because at the end of
the day it's
an elevation it's not the front
elevation it's going to be visible from
the street it's just a single elevation
with limited views from public vistas
without any face demonstration would be
a very difficult position to take as a
council thank you chairman
thank you very much uh i see that
there's no one else to speak so i think
i
would like to say something um stony
hills
back in the day there was an opportunity
to stop what was happened at stony hills
as i understand it officers recommended
the refusal of one particular
critical application pointing out just
to members that if it was allowed it
would set a precedent and open a
floodgate of stony hills that could not
be closed
it was as i understand a clear warning
and yet for who
knows what reason members voted against
the officer's recommendation
for that particular application and
those same members
reacted to later applications ringing
their hands as councillor
bell put it and sayings is terrible we
must stop the development that followed
and what has followed is a series of
refusals and
increasingly expensive appeals each one
lost by the mdc
at considerable tax uh taxpayer expense
and we've now arrived at a situation
where it seems we're actually getting
costs awarded against us in a manner
that appears punitive
that we're almost being wrapped over the
knuckles
for refusing things at stony hills
because we didn't
take the warning of the officers for uh
before so at stake here
um are the uh very evidently
uh impassioned concerns of mrs yates
and of course further further uh uh
fears of uh of cost to the taxpayer
uh because it seemed that the reason
why the officers have um uh uh asking us
to approve this is that they think we
could not win it
appeal i'm now going to go back to matt
lee and ask if he's
if anything that i've said is right or
whether anything i've said is wrong
thank you chairman i'll uh catch that
while the dangerous pass
um i don't think you can never say
there's ever
one moment that stricks or unlocks or
ties counseling per se
um i can agree that obviously there was
before i was here
an appeal was one that allowed a number
of dwellings in stony hills and
i do i can recall a number of
applications that were recommended for
future were approved by the southeast
area committee
um and then subsequently more
applications were refused and
i think we've pretty much lost every
single one at appeal um
from what i can recall that is you know
i do acknowledge that you know the
we look at the appeal for the six
bundles to the south of this site where
um mem members
we granted two then we subsequently as a
committee refused six
and they went to appeal and got cost um
i don't know if i was gonna say it was
punitive but what i will say is that i
was very shocked as a professional
officer
that an inspector gave us costs against
us for
and where he basically said the
applicant had an expectation to be
allowed to have six on that site after
two
which i was very shocked i wouldn't go
and see wordy how you have chairman but
i would say professionally i was very
shocked at that statement
um
we shouldn't refuse that i mean we
shouldn't approve applications just
because we're scared of costs
but on the flip side we shouldn't be
refusing applications that
should be granted permission um we have
to assess an application
what's in front of us we have to show
demonstrable harm as always um
every application will have some impact
on somebody whether it's an advert on a
street scene
just for everybody that's driving past
it whether it's an employment
noise and disturbance or pollution that
every application will have some level
of harm and what we have to do as
decision makers whether that's members
or officers
is consider the various material
considerations the pros and cons
and actually show that is that harm does
to such a level of harm keep saying word
harm
that it actually is a reason for refusal
um
i think the staple rehearsals report
goes through this application very well
um there is a distance of nine meters
this property is a bungalow and
generally it's considered with a fence
that there will not be
overlooking issues per se as a starting
point in relation to
that matter and i think members just
need to be conscious of there will be
some level of impact on the neighbours
but
is it to such a degree it wants a reason
for refusal and the professional advice
from the offices that isn't thank you
chairman thank you very much uh
councillor bell
thank you i mean i just say again this
is different none of the previous
applications
have had the impact that this one does
and i thank councillor chana for
mentioning demonstrable harm because i
do believe
not being able to use your bedroom not
being able to walk
along your landing to your bathroom
without the possibility of someone
looking in at you
that is demonstrable harm and that is
what the occupants of orchard lodge
are facing with this and i think yes you
know the essex design guide exists
for a reason you know there are
expectations
that you know of good design and i think
councillor messenger pointed out oh no
sorry counselor channel again
this is huge this is huge it's
19 feet was it i believe high
it's please you know members really
think about this
really consider the quality of life
of both the occupants of the ultra house
and
any possible occupants of this were it
built
and if you look at it yes it's contrived
and it's cramped
and it's over development it's not a
nice little
infill that makes a street of bungalows
complete
it's cramming something in that doesn't
fit there
thank you thank you i would just add as
my understanding is that as the building
has been
uh is likely to happen that that is
where
uh mrs yates fears uh
or has experienced people able to look
in through her bedroom i don't think the
bungalow will be able to do that in its
finished state
but i'm not making any judgments here
i'm instead
passing that over to you and we're going
to go to the recommendation now
uh with a with a view to voting on it uh
the recommendation that sits before us
and has been seconded as i understand it
uh is that this application is approved
and therefore i think we should now go
to the vote on that
uh and uh berna i see no more people
wanted to comment so berna could you
please take the vote on this
uh can i just check is that a legacy
handcuff
cancer bell thank you yeah thank you
chairman yes um so we're voting for the
officer's recommendation of approval
can you please state clearly for against
our abstain
um starting with councillor bassinger
against
that's the bill
apologies counselor channel
again boys
sorry apologies and cancer voices there
that's cancer boyce is
four cancer channel
against thank you caster helm
for the hot
cancer skins abstain thank you members
that's three for the application three
against and one abstention
right so
so this comes to a casting vote is that
correct
yes yes german
okay well uh i i'm hoping
uh that the uh reasons given
well before we get to that i don't know
whether we can do this before we get to
that but i'd like to say that if
i am really torn on this because autumn
normally on most um applications for
stony hills i would vote against because
i feel there's been massive over
development
in fact i'm going to stop there i'm
going to make that decision i'm going to
vote
against the officer's proposal
thank you so so actually then that means
that we have a four
sorry four against the applicant
the approval um three
for the approval and no abstentions so
that's
okay i'd like to add that as i
understand it
that is the last um
application that stoney hills which will
be under the pressure the enormous
pressure that comes from
the appeals process because from now on
we'll be able to put this
um normally but i do warn everybody that
this is likely to go to appeal
and we may fill you chairman it hasn't
been refused yet you've done it
it's not approved sorry go ahead
so go ahead bernard sorry sorry it's as
mr lee says it's it's just been um
it's actually the the approval has been
refused so now we need to deal with the
okay so we okay so the approval so we
now have to put a new motion forward
uh i'll propose that councillor um
schemes i propose that we
refuse the application do i have a
secondary
yes i would second that okay that's fine
well then let's call them
we need some reason yes we do okay
reasons for refusal please
folks
um can you hear me
yeah yeah okay sorry bear with
um i think it's style design
and bulk would result in a contrived and
dominant development which would cause
significant
and undue harm to the character of the
surrounding area
and the amenity of the neighbours
contravenes policies
s1 s2 d1 and h4 of the ldp
uh mike lee had a mike lee uh sorry matt
lee
how does that sound to you um
i prefer if members don't need reason
for refusal out there already prepared
if i'm honest
um but sorry i was just reading off the
um
off the uh agenda
supplements there besides them i don't
apologize they're never going to do that
before they because for a member of
publix from the outside it could be seen
to be that you'd already come in
predetermined so that's why the advice
members not to do that and if they do
to make it clear where they're getting
the wording from just for the public's
um knowledge um
members and i also add for transparency
that was the reason why birmingham
crouch
town council uh refused it as well
so there's a history there i do
apologize for some context it's always
helpful
thank you chad um
if obviously yeah it's design is a
subjective mat and if that's what
the if that's what the committee
considers then um
that's in their gift um i'll leave it
that was the officer's recommendations
for approval so
i'll leave that with you members just uh
looking to see if anybody else has i
know we're very keen on getting for one
strong reason uh can anybody else uh
come up for another strong planning
reason
uh among the councillors uh for refusal
other than the one stated by councillor
bell
i'm going to take that as a no
uh so we threw the chair counselor
channel had some excellent ones
through the chair uh council channel can
you
recall what those were well i think i
referred to
um when i was but i did have concerns
about the height of the
the proposal and in terms of its
position bearing in mind sunlight
um because i do think it will have a an
effect
um in fact the developments i think will
have an effect
on the amenities and living conditions
of persons in orchard house i do think
um on balance the officer's report i
think referred to demonstrable harm and
said there i think wasn't any
perhaps my material weight goes the
other way i think there would be
demonstrable harm with this proposal
that's
my view putting a different weight um to
the assessment
of um to the officers on this one for my
planning training
i am allowed to apply a different
weighting
um to issues raised and that's right
that's my personal consideration
thank you uh matt lee uh i think you
have our
um reasons for refusal uh the
uh the recommendation
uh now is that this be uh refused
uh and uh we go to the wrong call now
berna
thank you chairman yes members we're now
voting to refuse the application
um proposed by councillor bell um
and judy seconded for the reasons as
outlined by both councillor bell and
councillor channer
members i will take your names in
alphabetical order please stay clearly
for
against our abstain starting with
council passenger
four master beal
against isabelle for
how's the boys against
it wasn't very clear at all um yeah uh
four
thank you council channel counselor helm
yes counselor skins
four four thank you members
that's three for the refusal three
against
no abstentions so i
have to add my casting vote to that yes
chairman
i will vote for no that can't be right
no it doesn't sound right does it what's
going on i'm sorry countless games
voted this time round i did that's true
yes so it's three two four isn't it it's
four or four
four four three four
okay i'm a little bit unclear sorry can
we just clarify that can we just clarify
here
it's four for the refusal
three against that's more like it yeah
better extensions
i thought that's what i said at the very
beginning i thought uh
it sounded like it's not doing
this is for the refusal it's for further
refusal of the application
no this is okay okay right yes sorry
right yes
three against the refusal and no
abstentions
so yeah so that's carried
that's carrie right okay thank you very
much
okay so on to item seven and as you know
item seven steeple bay holly
holiday park have withdrawn uh so we go
on to number eight
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent and i have
none so i therefore uh thank you for
your contributions this evening
i now draw them yep go ahead
uh chairman councillor being speaking
it's very disconcerting to find an
applicant
is jumping up and down for a few of all
of us
it is off-putting and could i suggest
that the person's uh
applicants etc uh would um
control themselves a little bit more
because when we're deciding something
we need to have a clear mind and we
don't want people jumping up and down
waving our hands as if they're
which can influence us in the way that
we are vote
okay i i completely understand your
point um
but uh i would say that if we were in a
live chamber
it would be very difficult for people
just to uh
to avoid people silently making
expressing their joy at a victory
uh but i can see that it it can be a bit
of a distraction certainly so
uh mrs yates if you could please keeps
calm you can
uh so thank you very much for your
contributions everybody this evening
i now draw the meeting to a close at
1931 at 7 31 in normal time pm
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum
and to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much